with a three in the first position. And whenever two elements
agree in the first position, we fall back on the ordering
in the second position.
So that's the ordering that
we use for Cartesian products.
Notice that when we use this convention and we write n-tuple as strings, we observed some very familiar patterns.
For example, the Cartesian product of the
binary alphabet with itself is ordered like you see right here,
and you can think about these strings as being ordered numerically if you take these strings
as binary encodings of non-negative mixtures
and this generalizes
to any string length. Moving on to probabilistic states, we already know from the previous lesson
that a probabilistic state associates a probability with each classical
state of a given system.
If we have a compound system where we've taken two or more systems and we're viewing them collectively as if they form a single
system like we just discussed,
then a probabilistic state
of this compound system must assign probabilities to the elements of the Cartesian product
of the individual systems,
classical state sets. That's because that is
the classical state set of the compound system.
For instance, supposing
that X and Y are bits, we have this example of a
probabilistic state of XY.
The probability that both
bits are zero is one half and the probability that both
bits are one is one half, and so the two bits never disagree.
It's a valid probabilistic state of XY, and we can alternatively
write it as a vector
like you see right here and here you can see that we
are following the convention that I described a moment ago for ordering these classical states.
This is an example of
a probabilistic state where X and Y are correlated, and this is the sense in which the hole
is greater than the sum of the parts. As I suggested before, it's not simply that we
have a probabilistic state
of X and a probabilistic state of Y and we put them together, but rather we first put
the systems together
and then we think about
probabilistic states of the compound system.
To be more precise about
correlations among systems. We start by defining the
notion of independence, which is essentially the
absence of correlation.
Here by the way, the term independence refers
to statistical independence as opposed to linear independence
of vectors for instance.
It's fundamental notion in
probability and statistics.
If we have two systems X and Y and we have some probabilistic
state of XY in mind, then we say that X and Y are independent.
If the formula that you
see right here is true for every choice of classical
states a and b of X and Y.
One way to interpret this
condition of independence is that it says that the probability for X to be in any one classical state
and the probability for Y to be in some other classical state have absolutely nothing
to do with one another.
So, learning what state
one of the systems is in doesn't affect the
probabilities associated with the states of the other system.
If you imagine randomly choosing
some classical state of X according to some procedure and then randomly choosing
some classical state of Y
according to some other procedure that isn't in any way
connected to the one for X, like say if one person flips a coin
and another person in a
different room rolls a die, then this is the formula
that you would use to get the probabilities
for different combinations
of states to appear. The point of the definition is that independence is
when the formula is valid.
When we think about probabilistic states in terms of probability vectors, there's a simple formulation
of this condition
specifically if we have a
probabilistic state of XY, which we can express as a
vector in the direct notation
as you see right here. Then to say that X and Y are independent is equivalent to the existence
of two probability vectors,
cat Phi and cat Psi which by the way we can
simply read as Phi and Psi for the sake of brevity representing
probabilistic states of X and Y separately that satisfy this equality
that you see right here.
For all choices of a and b, it's essentially a
rephrasing of the definition in terms of vectors.
For example, here's a probabilistic
state of a pair of bits XY for which X and Y are independent.
The condition that's
required for independence is true for the vectors
that you see right here.
That is the probability
for each possible setting for the two bits is given by the product of the corresponding probabilities
for the individual bits.
For instance, the probability for both
bits to take the value zero is equal to one sixth, which is equal to one
quarter times two thirds,
and likewise for the
other three possibilities which can be checked one at a time.
For the probabilistic state we saw earlier on the other hand where we
have two bits that always agree and take the values zero and
one with probability one half
we don't have independence and that's why we say that
the bits are correlated.
Correlation simply means
a lack of independence.
A simple way to argue that the
two bits are not independent is to suppose that they are and to derive a contradiction
specifically if the two
bits were independent, there would have to exist
numbers q0, q1, r0 and r1